you were in the Chris Rock movie top
five yeah and you it was kind of a kinky
role you had to you know it was I think
by anyone's standards some of what you
were up to in that movie was so it was a
little strange he liked a little
backdoor stimulation my character mm-hmm
and now he was into that and you know to
each their own and did you know that
this was part of when you when you heard
that you were up for a Chris Rock movie
did you think no right I'm not I have no
idea I wasn't like calling my agents
being like you get me that booty
audition yeah so I got a call from Scott
roux and he was like I'd love you to do
this Chris Rock movie and I'm like Chris
Rock Scott Rudin like this is gonna be
awesome and he that he says I think
you'd be perfect for the part and I'm
like look at me go right I'm knocking
him dead right read the script okay
wait why did you think I was perfect for
this but uh turns out I was I killed it
yeah now what happens when your parents
see a movie like that and they see the
rule did you prepare them yeah no no no
well it's so weird because like when I
moved to LA they were like just don't do
pornography and I'm coming so close but
so I didn't I didn't tell them because I
was like I don't want to have this
conversation like you never had
conversations like this when I was a kid
that could teach me about the birds and
the bees so it's just it's it's always
been awkward right so they went and saw
it and then I just got a text from my
mom that was like saw the movie it was
funny daddy didn't like a lot of ribs of
mommy yeah
but then they saw it twice
they were like we went and saw it again
I'm like what yeah which is it's just
weird I'm my god the I just wanted to
make sure what they saw was there
because it's their worst nightmare I'm
sure wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]